[Musica]
il mondo rurale
cosa può fare il mondo rurale mondo
fragile e allo stesso tempo ricco di
potenzialità cosa può fare il mondo
rurale per dare un contributo alla
soluzione dei più grandi problemi delle
più grandi questioni del nostro tempo su
scala globale
cosa può fare il mondo rurale per dare
un contributo alla soluzione della crisi
ambientale e alla erosione di
biodiversità
secondo una ricerca della global crop
diversity trust circa i tre quarti di
varietà delle specie coltivate
nell'ultimo secolo sono andate perdute
i tre quarti scomparse per sempre poi il
mondo rurale stabilire dei modelli
innovativi che ispirino il cambiamento
in tutti i livelli della collettività
della comunità attraverso la creatività
attraverso lo spirito innovatore
attraverso anche azioni concrete in base
alla mia esperienza
questo è possibile è possibile portare
avanti questi modelli innovativi
attraverso una pluralità di progetti
grandi e piccoli aventi tutti però un
comune un unico comune denominatore cioè
la fusione la sintesi in essi di una
pluralità di disciplina arte agricoltura
ecologia formazione educazione scienza
tutti i fusi insieme in una sintesi con
la quale costruire lavorare alla
costruzione dell'evoluzione non solo
dell'ambiente rurale ma del rapporto che
la società umana a con la terra che la
società umana con le altre specie
viventi circa undici anni fa ho fondato
pole in aria
un progetto che mette insieme arte
agricoltura e attivismo il suo centro e
proprio qui a pochi chilometri da loreto
aprutino è innanzitutto un azienda
agricola biologica e allo stesso tempo
pone in essere delle attività di
educazione di formazione delle attività
culturali e allo stesso tempo è un
centro di residenza per artisti
internazionali che vengono appunto da
tutto il mondo per cerea cercare di
coinvolgere la comunità locale in
processi di reinvenzione della loro
identità e di creazione di nuove
economie rurali questo progetto che
abbiamo fatto qualche anno fa con gli
artisti americani futurefarmers dal
titolo this is not e trojan horse cioè
questo non è un cavallo di ad
invertire la simbologia canonica del
cavallo di come un simbolo di
inganno viene qui a in considerazione
come un simbolo di coinvolgimento una
scultura itinerante che ha viaggiato per
tutto l'abruzzo da paese a paese da
fattoria e fattoria da abitante abitante
raccogliendo le memorie della civiltà
contadina in declino e allo stesso tempo
anche i sogni le speranze le opinioni ma
anche la disillusione dei giovani
agricoltori dei giovani abitanti di
questa comunità ea formare quindi una
sorta di capsula del tempo e di archivio
dei pensieri delle idee sul futuro della
ruralità questo progetto ha poi
viaggiato anche oltre confine d'abruzzo
e
è stato presentato in diversi contesti
internazionali
e proprio oggi oggi il 20 di aprile
verrà presentato a san francisco allo
yerba buena center for di aids sia il
lavoro dei futurefarmers sia questo
questo lavoro in particolare oggi però
ecco vorrei parlarvi di di qualcosa in
particolare
qui una andiamo se riesco a trip e se un
contenitore di semi il seme qualcosa di
molto piccolo ma potenzialmente molto
vasto qualcosa di semplice e allo stesso
tempo complesso la cosa più
straordinaria che possiamo fare e
conservare i semi
la cosa più rivoluzionaria che possiamo
fare e conservare i semi coltivandoli
scambiandoli creando insieme una grande
raccolta di biodiversità una grande
raccolta di risorse genetiche stabilire
un interazione con una forma di vita in
luce che allo stesso tempo è però un
veicolo di conoscenza e una
testimonianza di civiltà secoli e secoli
di storia umana in interazione con
l'ambiente racchiusi in un click di
grano raccontati dal chicco di grano
questa è la filosofia di bob canard un
agricoltore visionario ancora attivo
oggi in california ed è la filosofia dei
futurefarmers e anche la filosofia di
radio instabile raddrizzabile un
progetto radiofonico che ruota intorno
al concetto del seme come veicolo di
conoscenza come veicolo di idee nel
tempo e nello spazio
inoltre va di un instabile è un
ipotizza si basa sull'idea che il seme
sia una sorta di social media cioè uno
strumento attraverso il quale è
possibile interagire tra le persone
broadcast è la parola chiave è la parola
che in inglese vuol dire trasmettere
vuol dire propagare diffondere questo
vale sia per i semi che per le
informazioni che in questi in questi
semi sono contenuti
questo progetto radiofonico tratta
principalmente i temi dell'agricoltura
sostenibile i temi delle foto delle
forme collettive di coltivazione delle
sementi antiche e altre tematiche
tematiche legate all'agricoltura
contemporanea è una forma di
propagazione di idee lontane dal luogo
dove vengono formate perchè questa radio
i contenuti di questa radio vengono
creati insieme dagli agricoltori e in
particolare abbiamo iniziato questo
lavoro degli agricoltori di resistenza
che lavorano piccolissimi appezzamenti
qui sulla montagna abruzzese insieme a
un gruppo trasversale di soggetti che
sono lontani dal tempo dal mondo
dell'agricoltura
quindi abbiamo economisti esperto in
particolare di di sherling economy di
media studies di attivismo resiliente e
alza categoria dei ricercatori che ogni
volta si aggiungono a formare i
contenuti di questo di questa radio gli
autori sono quindi insieme ai farmers e
la draga del tiziano bonini che sono due
autori e radiofonici radio papesse che
una web radio italiana
un'altra particolarità di questa radio e
che si
si emette il suo segnale in diversi modi
sia attraverso la web radio sia
attraverso la installazione di stazioni
radiofoniche temporanee come abbiamo
fatto nel caso del museo maxxi di roma e
anche attraverso metodi assolutamente
tradizionali un programma collegato a
questi contenuti che si chiama la banda
dei grani antichi è andato in onda su
rai radio3 ed è tuttora fruibile come
podcast su rapelay quindi la
particolarità di questo progetto
radiofonico e che dà la possibilità agli
agricoltori di far arrivare le loro idee
il loro messaggio in luoghi che
altrimenti non potrebbero raggiungere
perché la radio a questa particolarità
di essere uno strumento di comunicazione
estremamente pervasivo abbiamo avuto
anche il sostegno della european
cultural foundation e per portare questo
progetto anche fuori dai confini
nazionali in europa siamo entrati a far
parte di un network che si chiama green
art lab alliance e che mette insieme
istituzioni culturali che si occupano di
sostenibilità ambientale e e attraverso
questi siamo riusciti a portare questa
radio anche in altri territori rurali e
non ad esempio nella campagna inglese
nel dorset in scozia così come in città
come glasgow e edimburgo
dunque la particolarità di questo di
questo progetto è appunto quella di
creare non solo una nuova forma di
comunicazione per questi per questi
agricoltori mettendo insieme anche
creando questi contenuti trasversali
insieme a questi altri ricercatori e
allo stesso tempo creare un archivio che
è sempre crescente di contenuti legati
al futuro della ruralità questo è
particolarmente importante quindi non si
ferma alla trasmissione ma cresce poi
creando questo questo archivio dunque
sempre seguendo il filo del seme questo
fil rouge o in questo in questi ultimi
mesi iniziato a lavorare a un altro
progetto che questa volta a un focus
particolare sull'abruzzo si concentra in
particolare su questo grano che vediamo
qui che forse molti di voi conoscerete
questo è il grano solina dell'appennino
abruzzese un grano storico il più antico
di cui si abbia memoria in abruzzo ci
sono testimonianze del suo uso già 500
anni fa quindi in qualche maniera a
questo grande rappresenta la sintesi di
una risorsa genetica autoctona da
conservare e allo stesso tempo è una
testimonianza della cultura di un popolo
e del suo legame con la terra
questo brano è oggi oggetto di un
progetto europeo della commissione
europea che si chiama preparatory action
on european union plant and animal
genetic resources in agriculture
sostanzialmente si occupa di promuovere
valorizzare tutelare la biodiversità
agraria in tutta europa per il 2017 è
stato scelto un unico seme per questa
opera di conservazione ed è proprio la
solina quindi attraverso il consorzio
dei produttori della salina d'abruzzo
stiamo adesso lavorando
all'implementazione di questo progetto
attraverso una serie di azioni concrete
pratiche
la prima è quella della costruzione di
una filiera del pane di soli né perché
tradizionalmente questo grano è legato
alla farina è legato al pane
quindi abbiamo messo su una filiera che
mette insieme agricoltori mugnai
tecnologie alimentari e naturalmente
stoccatori consumatori
insomma tutta la filiera che si basa su
un disciplinare di produzione di questo
di questo pane e altre filiere
seguiranno in riferimento ad altri
prodotti sempre basati sul grano solina
ora questo della salina è quindi un caso
emblematico però non è l'unica cosa
vuole essere solamente il primo di un
percorso più ampio che vorremmo portare
avanti nei prossimi anni e che riguarda
tutta la biodiversità agraria bruzzese
quindi questo è il primo capitolo di un
discorso che riguarderanno solamente il
grano ma anche tutti i cereali i legumi
le ortive i fruttiferi per cercare di
conservare il più possibile di tutelare
la biodiversità agraria qui in abruzzo
questo progetto appena nato lo abbiamo
chiamato casa che sta per custodi
antichi semi d'abruzzo proprio a voler
testimoniare l'importanza e il valore di
queste risorse genetiche verso la
costruzione di nuove economie rurali e
non solo
coltivare la biodiversità nutrirsi di
biodiversità perché nella biodiversità
c'è la vita la diversità delle piante
coltivate costituisce la base biologica
su cui si basa l'intero sistema
dell'agricoltura è dunque fondamentale
mantenere il più possibile
ricca la biodiversità agraria per poter
affrontare le sfide che cambiamenti
climatici
di fronte a queste sfide sono sfide di
adattamento di resilienza e se le
varietà coltivate le specie coltivate
non sapranno adattarsi
se l'intera agricoltura non saprà
adattarsi non ci riusciremo neanche noi
allora quello che cerchiamo anche di
fare e di allenare e di educare a
riacquisire un rapporto con la terra sin
da piccolissimi e anche a chiederci
sempre da dove arriva il cibo che
mangiamo
quale cultura rappresenta l'autenticità
di quella cultura la sostenibilità di
quella cultura
ecco i bambini della scuola
dell'infanzia di loreto aprutino che
vedete qui lo stanno imparando fin da
piccolissimi seguono nelle loro attività
il ciclo delle stagioni
seguono il ciclo di produzione del grano
vengono con noi a seminarlo ne seguono
le fasi di crescita sino alla mietitura
quindi sono abituati fin da piccoli a
riconoscere la biodiversità e ha
chiaramente avrà una sensibilità in
questo senso ed educa attraverso
l'educazione attraverso l'apprendimento
attraverso l'acquisizione di un senso di
responsabilità che possiamo quindi
tornare ad essere dei cittadini
consapevoli dei cittadini attivi e
reinventare insieme il futuro del nostro
pianeta allora immaginiamo e inventiamo
il futuro ripartendo dalle origini
vorrei leggere un passo con cui si
conclude questo libro di lidia e clod
bordignon manifesto per un'agricoltura
sostenibile dice che per realizzare
l'ispirazione creatrice delle grandi
cose bisogna avere un occhio che sappia
vedere la natura un cuore che sappia
sentire la natura
una volontà che osi inseguire la natura
grazie
[Applauso]